a student at a catholic high school in
york pennsylvania says
he was forced to take off his black
lives matter mask before the ceremony
photo shows dean holmes wearing the mask
during rehearsal
about half an hour before last week's
graduation the 18 year old says when the
procession began
teachers and the principal told him to
remove his blm mask
since the students were given face
shields to wear holm said they tried to
get him another mask but he didn't want
one so fearing
he'd missed the ceremony he took off the
mask and entered the church to graduate
with his class
wearing a face shield here's what holmes
and his dad told me about the incident
all lives do definitely matter but black
lives are
at risk right now you know they're not
really safe
in their own skin so it's like
you can draw some attention to this you
know show support
now with the internet and social media
we have a voice
the outpour from such positive people of
every race has been so
wonderful to see
the school says it has a dress code for
the ceremony and quote any graduate
wearing a cap
gown or mask with any message would have
been asked to remove it eureka
wow and it's so nice to hear you know
his father and the son talk about just
the amount of support
that they have because it's not about
saying other people don't matter but
just really understanding this moment
that we're in so that was that was nice
of them
glad you got a chance to talk to him too
glad